but right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 51 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
salute the Lord anchorman for holding
the Lord's down last week in my absence
but I've missed my brethren daily so it
feels good to be back talking games once
again in the realm of the Lord's we've
got a very special guest metroid prime
for rumors Unreal Engine vs Xbox 1x the
future of pubsey and the decline of
fighting games to discuss so we gonna
get right into it I want to introduce
the Lord who I consider one of the best
young writers in the game similar to the
ILP this Lord was recently united into
the inner circle Network displays a
tremendous work ethic extremely balanced
viewpoints and has always been a friend
to tick and the round table introducing
the editor of TI cgn calm and the Lord
of computer science and RTS games the
direwolf and original Geralt of Rivia
welcoming back to the realm of the Lords
mommy Lord Samuel tobert how you doing
sir I am doing very very well my lord it
is fantastic to be back here with all of
you Lords of the round table and it's
fantastic to make my debut as a part of
the inner circle games on fire we are
all doing awesome let's get this show on
the road
that's good it go love it stick fam and
of course we have the Four Horsemen of
gaming was usual suspects at the round
table our combos with the Como's ain't
in yet you should be joining us in
progress
but of course we have the most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also
the lord of receipts mr. orth la profile
Illuminati himself Mahmoud Lord
sovereign you do exert didn't be here
with Lord Sam I wasn't here the first
time around so I have not had the
pleasure of being on the podcast with
him yet so yeah right yeah that was
definitely glad to have everybody back
waiting for addict to come to the door
yeah good to be back with the Lords and
of course we have the excess Gaber oh
the lord of combat sports who was a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than the premium experience and it's the
tiki torch extinguisher Oh lovely Lord
King how you do exhibit I'm doing
fantastic and bad at the same time I
mean it's been a great week and it's
been a terrible week um I lost two very
dear people to me one is my cousin Brian
Lorenzo prey is 47 years old too young
to pass and then I lost my binky Ryder
died which it did it and you know but
God removes God replaces so you know in
that whole thing I bow my head at a
moment of silence for them but God put
fight night in my soul let me tell you
about Fight Night last night
I have to say this right I have to say
the uptick because you know people used
to tell you stupid stuff you can't
listen to regurgitated crap out of
people's mouths
right because tell you that the fight
game is falling off when they tell you
that boxing is at an all-time low stop
listening to him and do your own thing
yesterday we had three
powerful fights right so what I'm going
to talk about our people on England over
abroad
let's go yeah there we go man it was it
wasn't building yeah Chris Eubank jr.
versus Charles rolls this is a champion
now my opinion Christian jr. is a star
but he's damn managed wrong because a
lot of times you got to cultivate these
stars and you got to match them properly
so they can shine and then you give them
great tests later on once they've built
they confidence once they've built they
resume his father Chris Eubank is his
manager slash promoter situation right
and sometimes when the daddy is so close
to daddy might have confidence in the
Sun and don't understand that the son is
not ready yet looking for the son in
there with the champion Charles gross
Charles groves is at least a foot taller
than his boys with a longer reach in a
nice right hand and what you got for the
evening was a thorough jabbing of the
face and a smooth right hand to the side
of the head cuz you bake with all his
goodness tried to fight through it but
he lost in a decision to Charles growth
my hat's off to Charles Grove and
listening to all the crap cubing jr. was
talking and proceeded to love decided
his face up to teach some good lesson
that you talk with your hands and not
with your mouth don't we had Devon
Alexander versus my man Victor Ortiz
that's the boy the head butted Floyd
Mayweather out of frustration and
divinity to give him debt for four hours
um yeah what he did yesterday with Devon
Alexander those two semi washed-up
individuals and this was our simple semi
watch so when you get to people yeah
when you get to fighters in the
Crossroads and
and they're fighting for that meal
ticket you get some of the best fights
brother stakes high-stakes bum fights
and these brothers proceeded to
entertain you for 10 smooth rounds of
hard fighting which I thought Devin
Alexander one man in somewhere poetic
justice a draw was given because
Victoria Chase is pushing a fight and
you know you had some people rooting for
Victor Ortiz with their heart like don't
give a brother keep fighting get a
swollen eye and he was in the mix it was
beautiful last night the final fight you
had Danny Garcia versus reals oh my god
you know I don't have too many man
questions about performance in these
streets Danny Garcia in this boxing ring
is probably one of my favorite fighters
he's not the flashiest he is not the
best boxer he is I don't know what's so
special about him that I am enduring
myself too but I guess as his death he's
fully hot the dude doesn't back down
he's like my dog Johnson Johnson is not
a year old yet but sir Benjamin Johnson
will kill for the king so looking last
night Danny Garcia
and reals they were pitted against each
other their Realtors will come at you
tank Danny Garcia is a sharp shooting
boxer slide to the slide a hard-hitting
counter puncher he hit wheels with a
right hand that proceeded to remove his
bodily functions from him it's torture
you did his brain with the right head
his whole body leaned out like he's
faded the battery from his spine because
he was going good he's frozen with the
jab came over the top I was so I'm so
tired yesterday but adrenaline can't go
for this fight game this thing that I
love that I hope comes across that you
guys can actually hear it and maybe
y'all go check it out I will say this
looking I did see a clip of it
and it was literally exactly how you
describe thought he was good after
getting drop he okay I mean the ref was
like okay you ready he's like yeah his
body said no thank you like you say
called his bluff and I'm gonna save you
from yourself I didn't know that was the
mate of it but I did that was one of the
best short circuit punches I've ever
seen because it just stopped him dead in
his tracks and the thing is that he
telegraphed it because he was like all
right he's getting tired
he's throwing out lazy
so he throws out a lazy left jab and
doesn't bring his hands back to the
front Emile the right hand came right
over it like he telegraphed the entire
thing it was one of the cleanest right
hands on sideways it was like a soul
snatcher soul snatching punch show with
somebody and it was like thank you I'll
take that soul King combat sports recap
I believe UFC is today I believe Derek
Lewis is the only fight I want to see
because he's in a heavyweight picture
and not at the holstee pay versus a
Cormier is going down I want to see
where dude where's this Derrick Lewis I
believe his name is dead um yeah he's
someone I've had my eye oh he's a beast
I just he's got to work on his weight he
cut you know you guys remind me of
Kinkos memory of like a heavyweight
young version of rampage its prime I'm
either aggressive you might like this
case I'm gonna look out for him he
fights tonight and I'll be from the
young you know good good contender so I
want to see where he places because if
he does well he'll be in the mix with
the steep a and God knows and I love how
Dana is working it over there he pitched
these guys against each other there's no
soft touches for anyone know the main
event we got cowboy Cerrone though I
like him I gotta give it a cowboy cowboy
come out there he's always gonna give
you a good fight some nights he's just
not air you get stressed anybody true
true and he's always gonna give you a
good fight and he may go out in a blaze
of glory oh he may flush this guy
Medeiros his heart he's an in-your-face
type of fighter so it's a big
like no doubt yeah looking forward to it
so of course it is law Cognito here
spreading that gaming realness on the
ILP not telling you what you wanna hear
but what you need to hit I mean it feels
good to be back yeah I was I was hurting
I was in the UK hurt yeah we miss you
anchor I love you bro really you don't
pick fight I want to confirm something
if King then I've been agreeing with
King he's been agreeing with me so we
got to confirm that right now and this
is how the King brainwashing works right
it allows somebody to believe that I'm
doing the initiation but technically is
not true though a lot of times he's been
right he didn't understand like before I
would agree with him cuz a lot of times
that he was right he just was so
cantankerous and he didn't like how
right I was with him you know he would
allow me to share in his addicts world
so that's why the lovefest it out to
Lord addict we got to get that problem
for you I caught my co-host IKONOS my
brother from another mother and the how
of the young wolf Bobby Lord pretty good
I just got off work yeah back in the
building
did you get a chance to see any uh what
kind of action get shout out to a my boy
in the chair who said what kind of
forever I believe it was right show on w
did you get a chance to see yeah you not
your and see you soon won't try see this
weekend Jeremy got to see a guy said and
we also have to chastise Lord anchor arm
I put a tweet out you know he did a top
15 of them I believe his greatest MCU
films
and unfortunately he had the nerve to
have the Winter Soldier at number nine
so effective immediately
Lord of the multiverse take part we hold
all gallop we effectively would like to
remove anchorman from the first pair
judgment I was gonna say he must have
been under duress in this situation when
he talked or Sam I want you to go over
there I think you'd be more reasonable
in lausanne we after we have to make a
petition someone with a balanced
perspective and viewpoint because we
really have call me sooner or later
today I gotta say this I gotta say black
pants is the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life all right now now how it
may affect other people's destiny
business my love and my feeling for my
people was so overwhelming to me as I
sat in a movie I openly wept throughout
the whole movie to be honest with you
I've only cried in one movie in my whole
life and I was Lion King and O king of
Safa movie know me I watched the
notebook is it's not that situation but
this movie affected me in a manner that
I didn't expect it's a movie that stands
on its own without any superhero is a
movie that has superhero elements you're
right it's all Michelle or chicken
spaghetti first-timer the chatter say he
said blasphemous Stephen a Smith word
that's right we gotta all band together
we got a stylist petition to save a man
from himself
the Winter Soldier thing he went in on
me yesterday we talked for at least an
hour when Laura Cognito showed up and he
asked me my top Marvel movies and he
didn't like my ranking I went to so much
I'm very disgusted with you right yeah
you you mean you have to have a side
ball you didn't like the fact that I
love age of Ultron and I love different
reasons is defined by the villain all
right
the motivations of each villain has to
be in line with the heroes in an
opposite direction
he has to have a motivation that he
believes to be so pure so right that if
you look at it from his perspective you
like he is kind of right though but he's
just doing it wrong like human genocide
because we are a cancer on this planet
it's completely wrong but it's not
saying anything that's wrong you know so
you have to say man I really feel for
him as a sentient being becoming
sentient and wanting to destroy the
inferior because the dominant species
always takes over we have done it and
this is how it go I get that as a
villain like as a villain his his
motivations not amazing because he fully
subjects to that he prescribes to that
completely 105 my thing is the movie
surrounding him thank you merchant Greek
name of winter so and yeah I challenge
y'all cuz I swear yeah I probably have
not watched it within the last year we
watched that movie because I'm telling
you right now I don't like Captain when
Lord saw Lord kibosh we was out in the
parking lot with no more loneliness we
were arguing black rank I got to rewatch
because to me it's so impactful it's in
its own thing right it's it's I think to
me what it's such a powerful movie right
so I got a rewatching and I'm gonna come
back and see where Black Panther where I
put that in the grand scope of things
but Winter Soldier yeah oh stop this
virgin that is neo flawless film but I'm
gonna stop because I'm gonna lead after
the more time we all gonna have to join
in on a multi
I know podcast motometers
exact collaboration ranking of the top
MCU movies right don't you learn how
they're volunteering me to be on another
podcast a week yeah you shut out the
undead might be the truth the premium
Britt all y'all we are coming for anchor
man's credentials for MCU films
shout-out to Requin yo but Ragnarok is
my second best friend so watch your
mouth that's what I am oh good lord what
if I not been playing this week for
starters I have been playing I mean come
on you all know me the X enhanced patch
for The Witcher hit and I'll be late
right I'm enjoying that I'm in no rush
whatsoever to complete this playthrough
it's just like you know a little bit
here a little bit there enjoying that 60
frames enjoying the high-res the HDR
it's all such good stuff such a
fantastic game such an incredible story
CD Projekt RED they are the devs they're
number one in my book awesome then I
don't know how many of you read my
impressions but I've been playing quite
a bit of Crytek's new game there's
enclosed alpha called hunt showdown now
how many of you heard that how many okay
so it was originally called hunt horrors
of the Gilded Age back in 2014 but
Crytek as we all know went through some
extreme financial problems Studios got
closed and fortune lost my goddamn rise
Crytek the main studio in Germany seems
to be doing a lot better and last year
at e3 I had a chance to talk to some of
the developers and see a private showing
for this new game that had re-emerged
from the closed IP and retitled on
showdown and the basic idea is it takes
place in an alternate universe 18 19th
century British Empire's at its height
but
there's something wrong in the world
colonies are disappearing there's these
mysterious creatures coming out of
nowhere it's all very gothic and
otherworldly very demonic very
disturbing so you play it's a
multiplayer a Mass Effect prequel right
it's a multiplayer game where you can go
in alone or with one other friend you
load up on all your equipment beforehand
so you gotta choose how many Molotov
cocktails you want to take whether you
want a double-barrel shotgun the
revolver any of that stuff and you go in
and the job you do is you take a
contract to find and kill some
particular beast it might be a giant
spider the size of a barn roof it might
be this butcher with like a twisted goat
head and ragged limbs attached to its
back all very disturbing visceral stuff
what makes really cool is if your
character dies in that match they die
for good also they have permadeath
almost like a perma death yes you
maintain a roster of hunters in your
employ referred to as your bloodline in
quotation marks and so you choose which
country you want to take you can
actually enter the match and then decide
now screw this I'm leaving and it's
perfectly valid you can just walk right
out and you can do that and so by doing
that you choose whether or not you want
to level your hunters up who you want to
retire stuff like that they're going to
be revealing a lot more of the world
building lore so it needs more
optimization it is definitely closed
alpha right now but I encourage you all
to pay like a death and Lord addict I
could see you at this big time here's
the best way I can describe the setting
is first-person blood board the first
ten minutes of blood-borne universe
Merson way did me with perma death in
the roster Wow the premise is that you
get put on this map with multiple
different teams of two right they don't
tell you how many that's the other
players are out there mmm really good so
this has been taking up a lot of your
tab now it's been I put about twenty
hours into the closed alpha right now
they're doing some server maintenance
and I'm waiting on a big patch they're
being very transparent they have a
roadmap of what features they're going
to be adding they're taking feedback for
literally everything they really want
this to be a success so I encourage
everybody here pay attention to it
because Crytek could be coming out back
on top you know what's funny you said
that
Lausanne is that oh I've always had
you've been a fan of like the Crytek
engine sorry I like I said all it with
my rise love I still think that is a
technological marvel for and you think
about it at that point the world yeah
the Xbox 1x had to connect still taking
the 10% extra resources the SDKs were
all you know what I mean like it was and
for that game to look how it looked I
remember putting a tweet out you know I
hit up everybody involved with the
project including just like bad I would
love just so if you think that it is not
gonna be a sequel man I would love a 4k
enhanced version I know to see it in
because it still hangs up now it's still
it's still whole CryEngine is a
beautiful thing
yes the engine in the world to optimize
but it is a beautiful back so Lube rate
used it and those shots of space with
the door he's floating around the
station it's breathtaking you know I
must say this because I'm still playing
through the game now and it's a labor
but it's a labor of love in a sense that
I played the first pray and I loved it
and I'm trying to wrap myself around the
game and to change the dramatic change
in the direction and where we're going
with these little dark monsters um it
just felt like it was lazy when they
came up with the monsters but I'm going
to keep playing because the premise of
them turning into things and like
ordinary things like that that
chandelier it's a monster so besides the
monster stuff don't you like the
immersive sim aspect of it like always
like that's the cool part of it yeah I
could touch everything me touching
everything
shuttle order Chris covalently to check
he said I have us guys heard of hunt
it's on PC watched last night's a mix of
puppy with boss fights yeah evil within
I've never seen dad was going no work
was good yeah we had to come for your
boy Lord a good man man we had to we
want a multiverse collaboration we're
gonna talk about those our MCU films man
good to see you in the chat so a lord
addict what have you been playing this
week I know you've been working but what
have you been playing what you've been
sneaking in um I kind of slowed down a
monster owner really put like 80 hours
into it only 80 I can't help it okay it
was a good game just just kind of burnt
out or just go like you actually started
touching something there are stuff I can
do afterwards they're called tempest
fights but it's like I really feel
comfortable with like fighting stronger
versions of this [ __ ] I'm fighting now
hmm so you kind of finished kidding I'm
like you know in the kiss me brought up
the fact that I didn't play any of the
big releases he bought last year like
even wood then - okay that's fair I'll
go back employed no doubt now III heard
a you know due to the Twitter universe
that uh you had that the howl of the
young wolf had to go out I want your
PlayStation selection it looks like you
had picked up some used ps4 games I
believe they were three of them and um
looks like people were upset with your
choice of uh until dawn being your
favorite I believe something to that
effect what's going on with I can't
really go into much of that I will
address these people on Planet X rated
show for the children I can't go into
what I want to say but okay I'm not
happy with some certain individuals on
YouTube right now but you're gonna have
to go into the planet xbox for that for
the real version of that because the
Last of Us they don't would hit anything
ball from there
wait what games and clanking uh the
order 1886 Oh
people are happy that uh that I'm
playing the order over the last of us
but what are in your defense explain to
the people your logic as to why you
picked the order first because it's
eight hours versus like so you want to
blaze that out and then you can get to
what won't need to get to so they just
manage to order at the order that's all
they matter and I'm saying that as of
right now with my plays Xbox Playstation
games of like three I played Final
Fantasy seven I'll play ten and I played
a blood-borne which I'm sorry everyone
in the chat blood ball kind of trash I
was coming there's a lot of searching I
want to stay something was a bad game I
have to force myself to play maybe it's
because I had persona it's thought that
I want to play more than it like making
me not want to play it more but like I
literally had to force myself to play
that game that is your opinion
this is your assessment we will let that
rock shout out to the Lords of the
planet Xbox I know they will be coming
for your neck when next in that chat
come from my neck all they want in the
chat
Lowe itself what have you been played
this week finished I finished analytical
losses again we can disagree for forever
but yeah I finally finished it got
through the colossi yeah just a
beautiful game and the best version best
way to play that game definitely let me
see what else so they did have three
tries at it to make it the best day and
give them that and I'm sure in 10 years
were pretty I'm pretty sure it'll be
live action real people like Celeste is
devious yeah to me in terms of
platforming this year it's it's it's
gonna be beat would you say her Celeste
rumbling would you would you say I
apologize I thought I was muted okay
sorry
you can mumble under breath again and
then Bayonetta to pick that up for the
switch and I missed it on the way you
hadn't fallen off my view by the time it
came out yeah I gotta for you to see it
on the switch it runs beautifully
especially in handheld mode it's still
kind of once your docket in 720p across
the board so once you dock it even with
TVs that do good upscaling is still a
little money not rather handheld but
it's a beautiful game no doubt shout out
the little braaap in the chat good to
see baby
that's what's that yeah no King what
have you been playing I'll play G wolves
right now I'm gonna tell you the team is
so thorough that they hit me up on
social media like always girl with them
guns yeah I see you I see you
brap going at a shout out the monkey boy
let's see oh yeah I got this the whole
squad is here yeah singer you got breath
you guys that's just us might do
everybody every I have such a legion
team is crazy we have four or five
groups running inside the chat but the
best feeling was yesterday shout out to
spineless sinister we wrote it down as
well and when we see one - I said
sinister let's go
he grabs a gun shot him in the face he
runs and he loaded his gun he's shooting
at me
I'm hopping I'm jumping I'm running I
ran inside a house I grab some bandages
I rolled my cell phone I'm like a
sinister how the hell you left me I was
one shot away he's a whole town away
from me look grab a book bag I'll keep
my helmet on I get my guns right I said
I'm gonna go hunt this dude this dude
has to die because he made me run into
mr. battle so finish this in the next
time he gets murdered I said good for
you good
laughing me in the middle of a jumping
though yes that did the Merc to mark
with the mouth left me in the middle of
a battle and the King actually went back
and got Duke and took care of his
business watch these guys don't you guys
get that yeah you got your little pug G
multiverse we do we do me anchor undead
Mike every now and again oh we get it on
we do chicken yeah I shout out my first
chicken dinner as much as I've this much
tank man's name on the show today was a
christen who did run on certain par
anchorman was part of the team but sin
and John did all the work the rocket so
let's go get we got to do that Big O
well so why Jane see who's your squad
usually one with Jensen who else
I don't play bug to you right now but
when you did it was usually sinister
John and oh yeah John shout out the big
bad John oh shout out to whiskey a
monkey we indoctrinated him into it
because he didn't understand how
addictive this game was and I said being
that you're ex-military you're going to
get the feeling of it and literally it
is yeah he was just - yeah so for me
like I said I was away but I'm gonna
came back I dove into a little bit of
crimson days and destiny shouts my man
Lord eat bonta's and I'll forget em neva
we did a flashpoint talking about all
changes it was a big article that a
doctor needs you put out please check
that out you guys got a chance it's on
the iron Lord podcast YouTube channel
for a point number four so we're talking
about all the changes he actually went
pretty viral man indexical Gary and a
lot of the Destin community gave us a
shout for that passionate article that
was written so I did dad how she played
pub G with the crew you're mean and
finally you got to give me a round of
applause
I have finished this is the police for
the switch Oh three mumps the game is
long but man did I love it oh that's
such a crazy ride is it worth you know
what it was it was coz what it what it
built - I didn't see coming
about you know giving out spoilers this
is just something that is very dramatic
that you have to make kind of like a
Mass Effect style decision and then
based on what you choose you got some
different outcomes and stuff like that
so apparently there's like levels of
endings and you know that whole bit
right now will say just like Mass Effect
I don't know if the actual ending itself
was worth it but uh what it led up to
was fantastic I am looking for THQ
Nordics part two out to do or Pradesh
out going baby get that shotgun would
you guys shut out the anchorman for this
dope thumb now whoa oh yeah oh yeah
Tommy I was lit but I still have to
challenge him on his them to you but
also I've been playing I picked up on a
whim Kingdom Come deliverance King knows
me well look I know King knows I used to
be a fiend for kings for you know we
were we found that game in the dark Liam
we women we I remember how we did it we
chipped in he chipped in half I chipped
in half so we sat in the dark the game
and it was a first-person it was I guess
it felt like the first Skyrim for us yes
it was like our first open-world Skyrim
where there's no direction up and really
telling you what to do
and you can go anywhere you want to go
you know and we were picking up things
that we saw skeletons and we're like oh
my god he's not gonna have that was my
first one yes so I when I saw it it
automatically hearkened back to it and I
knew you better get it and I was gonna
actually what was gonna because I was
hoping that you played it now that I saw
anchor had the dev on is on the
multiverse and I really wanted to listen
to that part because I would be catching
up between everybody's podcast yes
get some shoutouts to shoutouts a mother
multi-verse obviously please check that
um shout out to short pause gaming my
boy lord dude we're gonna get him more
soon um he had a great interview I
believe with the community manager as
well they had some real quick good
questions about it and also shout out to
nlg they're gonna have something going
on tonight please check them out again
Kingdom Come deliverance I'm kind of
champion in the game look I'll say this
about it it is so ambitious it's like a
realistic Skyrim you're talking about
open-world but you're talking about you
gotta eat you gotta sleep you can get
drunk you can overeat you know say you
it's just so many factors to it and um
now I will admit there is some jank bugs
I believe this was correct me if I'm
wrong Lord Sam I believe this was
initially like a Kickstarter crowdfunded
game for years right three many years
yes I believe back in began back in 2013
I'll have to look that up to verify but
Napoleon for some time I remember the
Kickstarter was announced years ago it's
been in development for a long long time
nary a golf area but it's it's really
ambitious in the combat like I said it's
gonna take a while to get used to it
kind of reminds me in a shovel of
piccolo short short pause it kind of
reminds me of it's very one of those
games where if you don't think you could
take him you can't yeah yeah man it's
it's it's you you can also fight
multiple people at once which is what I
like you don't say cuz in the beginning
is a scene it's like you and your little
cohort friends you're up to mischievous
stuff cuz they kind of like guide you in
the beginning you can only do certain
things and they're like yeah let's go
RAM sack and do some mischievous stuff
to some person's house and then it's
like the dudes come and see you
ransacking the house and it's like this
your crew or three and their crew and
it's like let's get it on and then y'all
fist fighting it out in the streets like
it's like you can you can pilot your bed
like if you're like oh no you're not
gonna jump my man I'm hit you from like
it's funny and it's like it's a
a lot of complexity to it I will say the
combat may not be for everyone it's one
of those things that you could tell it
if you master it it could be real fun so
we shout out the kingdom come
deliverance Xbox one X I believe is the
best version that digital frontages do
something nothing 1400 peed and
wrestling on our stuff the smoothest
Texas we still wait for that day one
patch to get the jank out cuz jank it me
go to kingdom come
also shower to get when I shout out to
shout out to lordy Lordy Lynn the RDX
crew because if it wasn't for dealer who
actually was the first person I've seen
tweet about the game I didn't I wouldn't
have known about and that's what kind of
led me into and of course I'm a
podcaster knows Lords we go get into
these topics you know saying it off but
first I got apologies last week for the
poll not going up as you guys know the
garbage poll the Lords of London
Internet we're not cooperating for me to
do anything or view anything from
YouTube so I could not put the poll but
we're gonna have a new poll cooking up
you know this week I don't know at the
end of the show so stay tuned so we can
get into these topics so I'm gonna start
off in place for Laurie attics I know
you jumped in late but I'm some
Lastman's going on we got on the 1440 P
announcement for I believe um Xbox well
next you know all that other stuff but I
actually want to start off with a
Metroid Prime are about so um first off
we know that uh we did hear that
obviously that Namco Bandai I mean echo
whatever they're always but um Bank
Bandai Namco excuse that we heard that
they were announced that they will be
working with Metroid Prime for and I was
the first kind of his hint we heard
about it but there's a new stuff came
out and seem to be confirmed by
Eurogamer it looks like they're updated
their post confirming it the development
my name call but then they said that the
studio was gonna be moved from our
Singapore to Japan's non studio and they
shout out to adopt trade youtuber doctor
I believe um or diagnose him as well
that um he actually started doing some
linked in digging and it looks like um
looks like they're definitely gonna have
like a senior online program and this
programmer is also the lead online
programmer for Ace Combat 7 so there's
some suspicions now going on that Metro
prime 4 is gonna have an online
component so I want to bring this to the
laws obviously we heard about the Namco
thing we heard about also in this whole
LinkedIn digging we heard about Ridge
Racer 8 being exclusive to switch cuz
he's also supposedly working on that so
I want to bring this to the laws we'll
start off with Lord Sanford's what do
you think about all of this what do you
think about Metro prime for possibly
having an online component from switch
okay so metroid prime for having an
online component it makes perfect sense
i think it's it's very realistic and
honestly it lends those rumors even more
credence here's why Nintendo recently a
few weeks back I think it was about a
month and a half
reiterated that their plan their
strategy moving forward was to adopt
games as a service the Nintendo is
recognizing that games need to have more
replayability they need to have more
content they need to support fewer games
for a longer period of time so adding in
an online support for Metroid Prime for
while their online service is supposed
to launch this year as well it makes
perfect sense you get more people
playing people who would have enjoyed
what is obviously going to be a
fantastic campaign just a couple of
times now they have a reason to continue
playing they can pressure their friends
like hey come on we can play this
together this is gonna be awesome it
makes perfect sense it fits with their
strategy and it fits with the current
climate of gaming as a whole facts facts
absolutely Lord addict what do you know
how your feelings are on Metroid series
I know I'll never get to talk to you how
do you always fairly feel about the
Metroid Susan and prime for being
announced into Lord sleep again retro
from for I never asked you like how you
felt about like the Metroid series in
general and like you know not when you
heard about the announcement for for and
that is possibility of an online
only in Metro Prime so what do you feel
about all the first thing about before I
even go into this is a king you can't
talk for this whole segment because I
know you gonna talk I don't wanna I
don't feel like hearing him really
playing the older ones because I was too
young I started Metroid Prime King shut
up these days like there's very few of
Nintendo's IPs that I actually mess with
these days yeah I could tell you've
cooled on you switch like you cool
big-time I can tell see what it Lord saw
Lord King would you guys feel about
these long that you if you came in on
playing any Metroid game it would be
prime so of course your perspective on
the series would be a little bit
different than mine's nice like I
started when it was you know the 2d you
know find everything you know open up
this segment to get to that segment type
of thing backtracking game and when they
went to the prime format which was still
backtracking it was still a great game
the first-person stuff regurgitate Lord
sleep is back I want to see Prime I want
to see what evolution is gonna be
because the crap that they released on
the 3ds the wedding of the bed then they
put out there we're racing no I'm not
but I understood it was a test ground
for a multiplayer mm-hmm you know you
know what Nintendo does is sometimes
they throw out a game a random game with
a good name on top of it to see if it
you know the sticks that's one of the
games that you will forget about you
know um sometimes the games hit like the
Zelda cross swords remember that like
it's for Zelda's running around on
screen so that was kind of weird but
they tried to do it again with the
Metroid type of thing
and they just wanted to see what works
and what they can push going forward
like Sam said Lord Sam said it's it's
games as a service
Nintendo understands and they see people
making money on for a long period of
time all for one product and what
Nintendo's never did was drop the price
of their games but now they can
implement parts in their games with DLC
that can get more money and more value
out of games I think Nintendo sees that
they're going for that and they're gonna
probably do it better than everyone else
being that their system is on dual
format no doubt charge the critic over
he's going so hard
no can't pretty much took the words out
of my mouth there I think you know that
Federation force was a testbed for this
sort of stuff even backing it down to D
s Metroid Prime hunters um it's
something I think when you talk about
games as a service prime prime is that
series that's that's that's perfect for
it is the first-person shooter you can
create a lot of content around that and
keep people coming back besides the
sinclair campaign um I think I think
Metro it's a perfect opportunity for
them to take Metroid and elevate it to
the level that a lot of people see that
but it's not really at you know in terms
of the public consciousness and so it's
gonna be interesting to see what they do
with it and adding online is is an
obvious choice um and what's interesting
is that I mean they've made statements
indicating that what they're gonna do
with their online in general is gonna
blow you away so I you know I don't know
Nintendo to be to be hyperbolic about
stuff and make statements like that so
I'm interested to see what it is that
they're doing with their service and how
that specifically is gonna apply to
Metroid crimes for Jimmy yeah I mean I
want to jump in too I mean
I'm kind it's funny as much as I'm
kidding I'm joking with low acting you
know whatever but it's just like oh
shout out to all the original G's of the
chat of mullahs man good to see you it's
interesting because um I'm kana as much
as I'm clouded Lord adding a little bit
I'm in the same boat because my Nintendo
history with Metroid is not that deep
like I've played them obviously a couple
but I've never really got like in depth
so when I heard about this and then I
feel about this way I feel or sort of
like I feel like the only thing lacking
as far as John Roos for Nintendo is FPS
now obviously we know doom came out we
know Wolfenstein
god bless their souls how they're gonna
do that poor let's be honest like for
the Xbox that a lot of hardcore FPS
that's a big thing so I think that genre
definitely needs to be addressed we are
then supposed to have a lab bowl
function you're supposed to put the
backpack of our bullet on and put it
around your standard FPS your campaign
is very much a standard Metroid game in
first-person format so it doesn't lend
itself to to the sort of multiplayer
stuff so anything multiplayer in terms
of you know PvP would have to be
something more in the vein of a regular
fps and that's what brings people back
in right zone I think that's my thinking
like whatever multiplayer is it's gonna
be more in the vein of a traditional FPS
because whatever Metroid Prime is as a
campaign is much different to a regular
FPS not you yeah so it's just like you
know for me it's one of those things
that I'm very curious about this because
I don't let's be honest like Metroid is
also as great as it is it's not really
the selling franchise for Nintendo right
about there are PC really doesn't do
like a Mario or Zelda you know so I feel
this online component could be pretty
huge you know
because you getting longevity to the
game you know so I'm very curious to see
how they attack it and then on the side
note you know I definitely am curious
about the you know the Namco involvement
you know this guy obviously has done Ace
Combat before see how that goes and we
haven't really got into this what is
what are the Lords feel about this Ridge
Racer 8 exclusive to switch stuff later
yeah talk to me Lucy well yeah with that
I'm gonna be honest I have no idea where
I'm at with that I really really don't
know what to say mean potential aside
let's just wait and see what happens
there's not really as much evidence not
as much smoke for a good fire going
there but who knows I mean stranger
things have happened so let's just
because I know looking me and you you
know in our early PlayStation days Ridge
Racer was like that was that deal number
one which raised was that deal it's not
that deal anymore so the fact that it
latches onto a console that can
revitalize it and named because I think
Need for Speed revitalized
its name by coming out with different
iterations over like you know just
different ways to play it and they got a
little pocket that they're in now Ridge
Racer needs that same pocket on a goal
it can it be the best racing game on a
go yeah it that'd be crazy right that
feeling of Ridge Racer Ridge Racer
is back you know what I'm afraid of
it'll probably be Ridge Racer HDR remix
um and you know this time it have tires
it was the most bizarre thing that we
saw in the PlayStation 2 and we shout
out to Lord
Rick who's passed away but he showed me
that the car didn't have any wheels that
at all
that was the Ridge Racer 2 for the
PlayStation 2 Ridge Racer whatever
version came out for PlayStation 2 now
when you play a game and you in a car
mode right the car bump is so close on
the screen that you don't see the tires
but if you angle it in a position you
can notice that there's no back tires to
that car just which one
walking back to those days and bring
back those memories looks big to the
boys I mean it's just funny because I
guess I've fallen off so much off a
Ridge Racer do the forcibly all know
forces for the most part the king and
you know you better get it in the chat
looking law solicitors there he's
defending his pub G honor because actual
factual people that was there that can
dis say it could sit there and defend me
himself seeing I heard the whole thing
singer was in the party with us who was
there who man dance and sinister landed
together we landed together and he tuck
tail turned yellow belly and ran all the
King we was Duffing one person I wasn't
like we were in a battle of four it was
jumping we were jumping someone punched
in the mouth and shot in the belly is
said to defend yourself because when you
do have a history of doing he can't
defend that I had to dive out a window
or get my life together
well he got murdered
the only things like I remember when it
used to be north-south like a graphical
showcase title station came out when the
Vita came out rich racing was the title
you put on yes this is graphical good it
was arcade style I had to drift but it
was always that graphical kind of
goodness you know the first games that
was improved upon the arcade board with
him he is Lamar it was better at home
and it was the showpiece apart from
liked ocean then it was the showpiece
but yes one I mean to kind of echo what
King said I have mentioned this to you
before kognito that is like to me this
which is the perfect test bed or dormant
franchises to make a comeback and
perfect for that I mean for any any
third party developer right that doesn't
that who's currently would not be able
to fit on the switch well you know for
power reasons or whatnot and it has
franchises that are dormant but they
know they want to put something on to
the switch and not just make it a port
it's ideal for these for these
franchises that haven't been used for a
bunch of years to see you know to see
where it goes and Ridge Racer there was
nothing wrong with Ridge Racer apart
from the fact that the field became so
crowded that you know there's no there's
no place for it but on the switch aisle
by itself why not no doubt no doubt
yeah man I mean I hear what the Lord's
are saying is it's gonna be interesting
to see how it does I'm but you know back
to Metroid I'm very excited about this
online component you know even if they
just do like some type of um I don't
know what is this 6v6 you know 30 frames
I'm going with the 30 you know as long
as it has some deep mechanics and you
know just to keep that game alive and I
think like you said Lois are like keep
my game was a service at doing something
I think I think this is strategic from
for what you call specifically from
Metroid specifically because they have
to do something to kind of reinvigorate
that from a sales perspective it needs
to sell more you know I mean that kind
of thing so uh yeah that's what I got on
a Metroid Prime for anything else for
the Lord before we move on all right so
are we gonna go on to the next topic we
got our and the Xbox one just made an
announcement I know uh tech Park has
actually went into it so we talked about
this brief
the 14:40 support has been Cummings
gonna come very soon it's in the preview
program right now so people with the
1440p monitors can get some love they
don't have to get the the down sampling
and then the second thing I wanted to
bring to the table was a Unreal Engine
there's been some controversy in these
streets with a Unreal Engine M exhibit a
will be um I believe there's a developer
it goes by the name Italian developer
milestone they're coming out with kind
of like a rally racing style games
called gravel and believe is coming to
all platforms Xbox one Xbox one next and
this is using the Unreal Engine now one
of the surprising things that the um
what you call TR death made was that he
said they were asked you know will HDR
support you know beyond you know all the
platforms and he said yes it will be
supported on PC and ps4 ps4 Pro only so
at that point they were asked again like
can you explain in why HDR won't be
available on Microsoft console so their
answer was that the one dev started that
the Unreal 4 didn't support it you're on
the platform yet and that's the reason
behind the absence oh that's exhibit a
Exhibit B child to Lord Khaybar sooo we
have been on Harada we've been on his
bumper we've been on his neck about
Tekken 7 and when the Xbox one i
enhanced will come because as we know
the ps4 Pro does have an enhancement I
believe it gets it up to about 1080p
correct me if I'm wrong Lord Sam I'm not
sure but I don't believe it's 4k on ps4
Pro no Lord oh yeah it's not right so um
yeah so basically Harada for the first
time after radio silence and tweets
after tweets about what's going on with
Tekken 7 as we all know it used the
Unreal Engine and um he said basically
that it will require a hefty update you
know due to the new hardware inside the
Xbox one X and the way memory is X
access
he said the spec is enough because
obviously Tekken 7 is um compatible for
compatible with Steam but he said any
requires a significant update to the
Unreal Engine and there is no plans for
tagging
at seven Xbox 1x enhancements on the
radar right now so I want to bring this
to the Lords I also we know about the
1440p stuff but I really want to also
dig in on this Unreal Engine situation
and what do we feel about whether it's
the dev or whether it's the Xbox one X
you know about this whole thing with
having the optimized games on it let's
start with Lord Sam our guest ok so
obviously it's not going to be the exact
same scenario no matter what it is the
reason Unreal Engine is so incredibly
popular aside from the fact that it's
very open source you can modify a lot is
because again the fact that it's so open
source you can modify the bejesus out of
that thing that's why is particular for
third party games and third person games
very easy to use engine very easy to
learn how it's recommended to beginning
programmers alongside unity you can do
some impressive stuff I'm gonna be
careful how I say this um I think it's
gonna come down to effort obviously it
depends on what customizations you've
made like okay I don't know the details
of what Tekken 7 is doing what
customized code they've gotten there
maybe that makes certain things more
difficult than others that's just the
way it is but I will say this Gears of
War 4 on Unreal Engine timming still my
boy coalition our Wizards of software
and hardest most talented devs on the
plant in my opinion when it comes to the
technology Gears of War 4 as far as I'm
concerned is the most optimized game on
the planet with that statement based on
ILP 50 that went bad that's all I got to
say continue 4 update that lets run at
well over 1080p 60fps HDR and not just
any HDR mind you we've had HDR in the
beginning with this but incredible high
quality HD are some of the best
implementation is not right
there's a segment between Lord saw
versus HDI it was visible floor versus
janitor classes and man it wasn't it and
lords he's gonna really beg he's gonna
say exactly what I said
the shadow Colossus is great for them on
the Xbox platform here because that's
where the discussion our implementations
it's an incredibly well optimized game
and it uses Unreal Engine 4 at the same
time the coalition are some of the most
talented devs when it comes to hardware
on the planet so it comes down to the
developer and how much how many
resources they're willing to pour into
it whether or not we think it's worth it
that's what it comes down to it's gonna
require a lot of work he didn't say it's
impossible he didn't say we can't do it
he says gonna require a lot of work and
then so therein lies you know the
question how much work is he gonna is he
willing to put in at this point you know
they're working on Soulcalibur you know
they're working on things like so it's
just a matter of whether they think it's
worth it to pour the resources into
doing this for this particular platform
and it's easier to do on the other
platform at this point in time um it's
it's the same thing I was saying like
when it when this first came out I'm
like wait a minute
he said HDR isn't available for the
platform yet and I'm like well HDR was
implemented on the air on Xbox before
PlayStation period like so what do you
mean it wasn't available for the engine
the engine the first taste of HDR that
the engine had was on xbox like it
doesn't make any sense to me it was just
like it's it's a matter I don't never
want to call anybody lazy right
absolutely want to refrain from that
when I say that but it is
using it it is very confusing because
they make it seem like it is this this
mountain maybe it doesn't make any sense
shout out the Deaf signature he's
correct me correct him if he's wrong
he's saying fortnight has HDR and that's
on the real engine some confusion I have
probably had a couple of developers
working on it and said let's lap this
together and he thought that it was
gonna fly under the radar he was trying
to do it like how they move back in the
days you can't move like that anymore
these dudes are dissecting every last
patch every last DLC every piece of code
you have people digging through coal to
look at what was thrown away to say oh
he didn't do this they're calling devs
out now so no more of that and I'm not
calling any dev lazy but I'm trying to
tell you is don't put it out if it's not
ready don't have baked anything if it's
not ready because you will be dragged
through these streets and these guys
with these tiki torches and these khakis
are not plain you understand like did he
turn something that was supposed to be a
positive into a complete negative how
would you say that Unreal Engine 4 oh
you know it was real hard to put the HDR
in it [ __ ]
let me explain one part to you it's
baked into the system so when you say
that and you have other games using
Unreal Engine a yo game can't you're
looking wrong you're looking bad so they
should addition how hated they should've
just waited play not a mind you Tekken 7
on Xbox one was undercooked from the
beginning of darkening it was like
like 720 it just seemed like the the
same amount of effort was not put in to
get it at least closer to up to speed
with the PlayStation version so from the
beginning so at this point it just seems
like it's a and then shout out to little
brat because he sort of echoes what I
said like deaf cause they're looking at
it from a business perspective single
pane is annoying in the lifecycle of the
game right is it worth it putting this
amount of money and resources into it
who's gonna still be playing his game
but here's the thing Lord his ding Louis
off and this is where I slightly
disagree is because we've all seen since
the Xbox one X has jumped out right
before seeing that digital foundry is
the first to jump on these patches it's
almost free publicity to get an Xbox 1x
patch and they do these comparison
videos right to the point where you got
you know other devs correcting stuff if
anything goes wrong it wasn't optimized
right shoutout to EA in titanfall in
respawn when they had a little snafu I'm
saying at first so it's just like it I
just struggle with the whole idea of
like okay from I'm not saying it's not
expensive you you may be absolutely
right gloss off like it could be a dev
cost thing but I just struggled that
like by not patching Tekken 7 on Xbox
one X like how does that benefit you I
like I I just don't see it you know me
as far as like what if it was a patch I
could see so much pub coming to a people
it kind of revitalizes the game people
look play look like Lord saying like
he's going back to Witcher right now
people are digging in the crates on the
Xbox one X just to see what a 4k
enhancement can be can be and my thing
is okay even if they can't do 4k or
1440p can we get it to 1080p it's like
can we at least get that I just feel
like again I don't want to say lazy
never want to disrespect a dev and you
know shout out to the Lord of computer
science Laura salmon thing I will never
do that you know we're techies but it
just feels odd to me that they look at
it like this it would benefit you you
can hurt you can call that it's
perfectly acceptable to call out the
decision as very odd in the
there's other contradictory examples out
there this is so strange to me lord
hedak I've known you're not the biggest
Tekken guy but like where you at as far
as this whole thing you know as far as
unreal and you know devs you know as far
as the Namco situation and also this
game gravel I believe that's a Joseph he
has HDR on ps4 but not on xbox uh I
guess that people want to take pitchfork
for them let them you have no Barry god
this you can't not what if it was
highlighted about a game but its
gameplay
I'm tired of that okay he's coming from
a standpoint where he doesn't have four
came he doesn't have his 1080p TV I'm
still the same way my developers looking
about more what a game looks like than
what it plays like no I understand that
about what the you know your your
priorities but my question is based on
the format of what we've seen so far
we've been seeing like all these titles
getting announced that are supposed to
be xbox one exits right but for whatever
reason you know this particular title
when we've seen other examples when you
know games have been you know upgraded
even on ps4 pearl you you don't have any
issue and you have any stance on it he's
like yeah guys remember it's a small
group of gamers going back to patch
games so he says from a resource
standpoint he's saying that might be a
factor any other lords want to jump in
before we move on alright everyone's
good all right so that's what I had on
that and the Aussie we didn't really
talk about the Lord fell about the 1440p
monitor functionality added for Xbox one
X's in preview program right now to give
other options give you more options to
any game I love it I'm down with it if
more resolution modes is available to
help whoever has what to get the best
out of their game and their television
set
and they audio setup yes I'm down with
all of that absolutely we are going to
move on Lord King you've been out here
in these pub G streets what's going on
alright so um pop G is doing record
numbers and everybody's you know playing
this game and droves you have teams you
have everybody's getting on this game so
and it's in the preview program and
constantly what I received from people
talking to me and Sweetman and getting
at me
did they patch it up did they do this
did this happen to it because maybe they
got on the game and they didn't like it
was herky-jerky in the beginning maybe
they get got on the game they didn't
like the resolution in the beginning but
the game has been constantly evolving
week to week with updates like regularly
that's fixing and enhancing the gameplay
they're changing stuff around because
they listen to what's working and what's
not working and remember it's coming
from a PC picked space to a console
space so in doing so you have to change
other things around tweak other things
because the gameplay is completely
different when you're playing against PC
and console now my thing is being that
if games are in the preview program
should they have a higher level of
transparency to show a roadmap going
forward so the investors and people that
are investing in the game can have
confidence in the game that the game is
going to move forward at a timely
fashion like different checkpoints this
time we will be here at this time we
should be here and if they are not at
that point
should they be held to a different
standard because some games go into
development and they don't have to go
under the scrutiny but if you put your
game out and you ask them for money for
your game while it's being developed
shouldn't you be held to a higher
standard you know a higher level of
training going forward mmm Lord Sam
right
we have moved the title yeah definitely
um I think any game in a preview program
should have a roadmap for people who
purchase buy into the game at an early
stage and having they should give them
an indication of where they want to take
the game now in terms of giving them
concrete points that they're gonna be at
a specific time frames I think that's a
little tougher I mean I when you talk
about resources and how they how they
use those resources that the money comes
in and team size stuff like that as it
fluctuates it's not an easy thing to to
give that goalpost and say we're going
to be here at this time because chances
are they're gonna disappoint people with
that but I just think I do think a
general roadmap for where they want to
take the game does wonders to keep
people invested in your vision for the
game
and be willing to you know have a
willingness to keep giving you money
because when you look at something like
Ark right when Ark and that it initially
came out it had a roadmap for where it
was going initially and then when they
announced that they were charging there
they had DLC and they wanted to pay for
that in addition to that right some
people weren't up in arms but at the
same time it was it was a a fork in the
road from the initial roadmap that they
had so when they when they saw what the
content was and when they saw where they
wanted to take it you know obviously
people were miffed at having to pay
extra money for it but at the same time
they understood that they wanted to take
it to a place where they felt the
players would be happy with the game
well happier with the game so um I think
it's in their best interest to give as
much of a detailed explanation of what
they want to do with that game in the
long term and where they want to be and
I just think it gets people I came who's
not generally doesn't subscribe to stuff
like this it would get you more invested
in more willing to drop that cash on on
something that's unproven yeah I mean
this this is this is a good one um a
love a love this topic we're looking
because
we all get into the whole game preview
annex so to speak right um you know
we're paying for a price for a game
that's in preview but at the same time
you know what obligation does the dev
have to the community to let them know
and I think I'm gonna I'm of the mindset
right now it's like I feel they kind of
have to do if you're not gonna do a road
map kind of like like check out the
Bungie that was finally kind of really
implementing that that we got a scene
okay this date we getting this this date
we're getting that you know I think even
like a developer blog or on your Twitter
feed with the community you kind of got
to keep them up two breasts as I think
this is like the Community Managers job
like he has to get out in front really
say what's going on with this preview
program and um you know that's just
where I'm at with it because here's my
thing with puppy I love pub G my things
I'm wit Lord King in a sense like what's
next what what's gonna be the end game
like talking about things at least talk
to me about future plans
I thought the franchise for where you
want to go with it or you know hey we
experienced this and again it's weird to
give Bungie credit right now with all
the snafus if destiny to but you know
what we've been when I've been doing
these flash points with Lottie bonta's
is that this is what they're finally
doing this is what we've been wanting
for the longest tell us what we're
getting which at least if you can't give
us a hard and fast commitment date at
least tell us okay this is you know
spring of what you we're looking to add
this this is when we're hoping to reach
these these deadlines or guidelines and
stuff like that so that's what I got
what are the rest of Lords feel about
this no I agree I mean even again the
game I talked about much earlier hunt
showdown which is in the closed testing
alpha it's years away from being
completely finished they still have a
road map of the feeler pipes weapons and
all the different stuff they're gonna be
adding now I love pub G okay I love it
I play multiple games almost every
single day if I can it's fantastic if
you're with a squad there's really
nothing quite like it mm-hmm
it is in greevey it is yes that being
said it behooves the devs especially
after the success they've had
even if they hadn't been successful no
players what it is they can look forward
to like is this it that's not
necessarily a bad thing but just be
honest and tell us is this it is all
we're going to get is new maps new guns
and maybe a couple new vehicles here and
there but it's going to be the same
gameplay loop or are you going to be
doing something crazy are you gonna have
five teams of twenty you know like a mad
max setting with dozens of vehicles in
an empty desert plane Ellis just tell us
what you're doing give us a basic idea
don't we're not gonna put you on a time
constraint that's the entire point of
game preview that's the entire point as
it removes the time obligation it does
not remove the clarity obligation or
absolutely get some I see one jumpin no
real quickly just on that the desert map
stuff as it's been seen like people if
they're sort of leaving pub G from the
PC side because they're not happy with
the desert map doesn't matter to have
enough cover things like that I mean to
the point where people are actually
removing the ini files from their
install so that they automatically get
pushed to the to the island map and
don't get pushed to the desert map so in
a way the PC is serving as a testbed for
Xbox preview of what they're going to do
so again the clarity and the clarity in
the messaging in the roadmap is
essential to let people know where
you're taking the game obviously it's a
map they put in the game at some point
it's coming to Xbox but maybe it comes
with some adjustments based on what was
being seen on the PC side facts
important yeah shout out to lob rapid
each a he just dropped a bomb he's like
you know what's the incentive for a blue
hole to show us an endgame or any of
these things when people are still
buying the game in game preview so he's
attacking badass for the loss think
about that that question answers itself
the fact that we're buying it in droves
is the incentive and that's the wind of
game preview it's a success build on
that be clear it's not I was going in
work when you're talking about the fight
talking about Shawn Porter as an athlete
he's not really a boxer and Danny would
ko him that that's answering you refine
you but anything you sitting here trying
to poach my people bro
you try to push my people are you beasts
women and chicken dinners you have never
sold no chicken dinner ever step on a
mat where my team exists we will wipe
you off the map you wouldn't be no
dinner for you you will starve for a
week take out your squad Oh Duff you are
with my hands and put my guns in my
pockets you really need to talk about
joining me I don't know what's good this
is the gauntlet being thrown down all
over your podcast I'm telling you right
now the day they implement that I can
pick who I fight against I'm fighting
against your squad and we're gonna
murder your wholesale and we gonna
twitch Tremont yeah because you said
something before life oh you the king of
predictions that didn't happen I predict
this we're gonna murder you wholesale
and I'm gonna kill you first
the true king of what keep my mouth shut
because a lot of people understand
[Laughter]
I just got home I had to let you defend
your honor you smirk throughout this we
finally got through dirt on your name so
we got black pants and stuff real quick
don't you just saw it we went on I'm
gonna do spoilers that kind of thing and
then also you can you can defend your
honor with pub G the floor is yours
lytic I have no honor to I don't have to
defend my honor if you seen the end of
fo G or not at the end of a black
panther you know what happens right
that's a Bryan Singer rewrite I will
rewrite that right everyone says
language slip-up a we see moderators
that everyone loves it so everyone would
activate comes the theme is language I
love it
yeah overall impressions of the movie
just now no spoilers just yeah I know
you gotta save it for your show just a
little slight impression how you felt of
it what it ranks where's that what you
as far as movies or just as far as a
super movie yourself as a superhero
movie I really it's unique enough like
in the the overall structure of the
movie itself is not like anything
particularly new but it's it has such a
unique spin on how the plot is achieved
and just everything I walked away
thinking like care cuz I didn't think I
would enjoy yes I walked away thing like
om Baku
yeah he's in the comics he's just some
nobody guy like some psych second-rate
villain kind of deal like just to have
some like civil tension in Wakanda but
they they make his character way more
interesting mm-hmm and they give him a
little bit of redemption and I had loved
that concept in a day no Kahlua again in
the most relevant movie of the year
back to met it was a slit I walked away
from it and thinking this is entirely
relevant by it didn't it didn't feel
dated per se there were there were a few
little things like okay so I was we
watching all the Marvel Cinematic
Universe movies over the last week and a
half
spoilers so I was rewatching a lot of
the other ones a lot of them feel really
dated like Iron Man - feels really dated
already not really just in terms of
structure and stuff for this one this
one feels like it's a more prep book
like it feels like if you want if you
think it requires a second viewing yeah
yeah I think didn't require a second
viewing do you honestly anybody
understand like my jokes is for real so
they will get I'm totally different but
y'all hear me in the podcast hey y'all
know this is a different I of peaking G
king when you get the room and you play
with me add me on xbox and I guarantee
you is a fun fest time you will not go
back to anchor
damn can vouch for this Sam's on the
squad where no more I'll hand that out
to Sam Sam add me come play with me for
today tomorrow whenever you want
whenever you like I guarantee you'd be
like your anchor this kind of hang out
with our matches are anything but boring
our matches are not wrote tired of let's
get this over with
ah no I was like we were playing last
week or is it it was on Friday wasn't
Friday and we were playing one match and
this is in the same match I think about
I could I got every what I play pub G
every other match now I get disconnected
from a group so I had to drop it a
little bit later it's why I have to make
my way back to where the squad is I
don't drop with the rest of the squad
hmm and so I make it back I think of
baby died twice out of a hundred drops
or so where I don't make it back to the
squad but this last time we were playing
I think we tried your gig that's me yes
yeah but we we ended up doing it and I
picked up a jeep I didn't have any
weapons and so you know the deal is
we're coming back and so I'm I'm
bringing the Jeep over to pick them up
and we're we're like really inside the
city and it's real close real tense and
I can't believe it over the Jeep around
too much and so I'm picking I just
picked up undead and I was about to pick
up Sam I think and so I'm I I see
there's a guy right there with a a K and
he's like oh snap
so undead drops out of the Jeep I jump
out of the Jeep undeads trying to like
get position to cover I run up to a bare
fist it starts punch her in the face
confused he's like what the hell
it's like I got them I got them kind of
weak but I got I got knocked down but so
you just told me a story that you hopped
out of G beer fist and got shot put on
your knees we stole a package and brab
sat there and got the chicken dinner I
could tell you that I guess so many
chicken dinners I don't have to sit and
take pictures and post them squad MVP we
eat well over here I'll tell you they
will leave your squadron with jumped up
the pub G roadmap quad topic so all my
question to you because I saw you made a
caveat about this that LAN cake has to
suffer further the drop it is morals and
for the game topic in reference to
preview program maybe being more
transparent with road maps or should
they be mandatory what's your whole
thought process on that in general I
think for grant for game preview games I
think having a road map is almost
required no I think that it does need to
have some sort of road map I think a
good example is like what's the game I
was short of III 2016 it went game
preview it's still there now but
supposed to be and getting out of that
pretty quickly happy few yeah well we
roadmap and they they show pretty
regularly this is what the plan is no
nothing for a game like that where it's
in there for a long time and it's about
adding more content but anything else I
think yeah you show a road map now Mike
we know did you know
oh they could say I'm sorry yes they
would pub G though I don't really think
they require a road map because they'd
be updated so frequently
and the game already came out of that
early access on PC it matter it came out
and so we know it's coming out on Xbox
it's just about more stability patches
and adding that other map we're done
gotcha so your feeling is as far as on a
preview program in general like you with
the whole roadmap but your whole thing
is because pub G has already been
released on PC this is a unique
situation we've already known what's
happening over there that there's no
requirement on their end even even to
Lord Brad's point what the there's as
far as incentive with the fact that they
have making so much money and the
success of pub G I don't think they're
obligated to what a games already out on
PC that's already had its full release
you know what the ultimate goal is not
you get it get it to the PC version and
you can if you can do that you have no
need to have your own like officially
stated roadmap because it should be
apparently clear mmm-hmm but on the
other hand like if it's a game where
it's like okay let me have a fuse of
what I don't go to or uh a long dark
where the game has not come out on any
platform yet it's on early access I
think you do need to have some sort of
romantic left on the whole pub G
situation and the who's clan is better
and now what I would like is since
what's on Xbox and you got everybody's
got this welcome you all know squad is
so much fun
like squad squad is where it's at
totally agree Lausanne like I would love
them gonna have for the Xbox like you
really utilize you know the azure and
the cloud servers and be able to either
host or get your own you know squads
versus yeah or just yeah private server
so we can just all be part of that 100
you know I mean almost like a 1 versus
100 G like let's go let's let's make
that that's a strength of the platform
let's utilize and I really hope with the
success of this game cuz it's so much
fun i watch looking all the time I jump
in there with you guys as much as I can
I see the cruel or dank I've run with
you as well I see the crew I see the fun
and how fun would it be would be like
the entire tick network you ready
inside pub G like it would just be so I
see I think the potential of this game
is so great and I also just want endgame
stuff not no disrespect you know having
a mock neck shirt and shoes it's nice
but like just something else for from an
in-game perspective to keep you also
coming back because it is so adorable
ooh Chris you gets a little crazy
[Music]
cosmic something I just I don't want I
just want to see how they implement that
you know because we know battle royal is
fun its addicting I just also what like
oh no maybe some prestige kind of things
to reward the people like you always
have to be cosmetic though regardless to
what you can't even start a match with
something that gives you any form of
advantage because it takes away from the
whole of the game does the purity of the
game the only reason why I play this
over fortnight and this is the only
reason why it's super base level it's in
its purest form the purest form is the
fright of when you look over and you're
falling out of the sky with your
backpack and the guy opens his chute
next to you now I going to run from this
dude or am I going to confront this dude
and he's saying the same thing and in
that raw nature of it that's where the
complexity lies because you have the
flight or flight and fight or flight
moment and that's where that's where the
game is at its best and then your team
comes in Twitter your boy comes over and
he helps you like Angus said he got down
on his knees but his team took the dude
out how good did that feel and you
saying pick me up let's go let's go
that's so great you're jumped in the
Jeep and you're proceeded to go on and
get their loot a house and the
camaraderie that you share in this game
I think it's the best team-building
because you get to learn people's
tendency yes right you're like I'll get
in the tub
yo shout out the Lord sister for
brainwash it look big badger
just get the take off all your gear now
you know if you come across a 4-time
scope and a sniper who's the best sniper
on your squad if you know who's the best
rummager who will go out and clear out a
town and let you know who's the scout
who's the role so you also know who
coordinates things or who's looking at
the map and who's looking at the time
you get to a point where y'all a
well-oiled machine you're functioning at
a level that it's beautiful and then
when they all come together you get the
chicken dinner oh man yeah I'm at a
point with this game that I haven't been
with a lot of games that is preventing
me from playing game yeah that's when
Lord Ram is saying Iran is saying it's
so it really is it and in what I like
about it it's like quick burst you can
just get in and this week for the first
time laughing so hard
absolutely so top files better get
corrected tomorrow but you are what is
going on with the fighting game genre so
up to us he's gonna bring it up he was
gonna bring it up and then he changed
his mind
yeah he put him and then the funny thing
is when he brought it up I didn't really
see anything to it I said wow I see men
sit in this this this is kind of news to
me and like in this in the subsequent
week though like more stuff has come out
it kind of makes you wonder like what is
going on with the fighting game um so
this is the thing with me
I want to know from you guys what do you
think fighting games have to do at this
point in time in order to stay relevant
well if the market not not not
necessarily not necessarily to the hard
cook the hard core is I'm gonna stick to
the fighting game genre
the defining gunner is niche but at the
same time you still have your hardcore
that there but at the same time when you
see different models now especially like
with the news that um for honor is
continuing to thrive after a lot of us
thought that game was dead
um they're on they're on season 5 of
content and they I mean they have a
number of players playing that game and
then when you have a true fighter yeah
but I mean the one on one aspect is the
star of that game maybe so but it's an
engagement game so you can chance to
engage or not engage and you can engage
where you feel like you had an advantage
type of an game that's part of my
question no that's why I'm like Roger do
you think a traditional fighting game
has to do that sort of stuff to stay
relevant especially amongst people that
are not the hardcore doesn't need that
that sort of like you know that sort of
grindy sort of loop thing that these
games have in order to stay relevant
with people that are not hardcore
fighters mmm and I know and I say that
because I mean like some of the stuff
that King Act was was gonna bring to the
table but Dragon Ball Z fighters kind of
percent of his player based on the PC
right and they could be varying reasons
for that um the the recent news of
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite where it was
it was omitted from the Capcom World
Championship Tour its omitted from Evo
and the word is that it's gonna be
removed from digital marketplaces by
October so I mean the game is
essentially an unqualified flop mmm
basically especially for that series of
games and how well they've done in the
past and then again any contrast we look
at for honor a game that people thought
it had a nice little it had a nice
little push at the beginning its orders
no more and they just keep supporting
and supporting and supporting it right
like I said they're on
season five of content and the
playerbase just keeps growing so what do
you think has to be done with fighting
games in this day and age to continue to
keep them relevant and this is good
question first because I information
privy that's why I was bringing up the
topic I had the information on the 80% I
had the information on the evil I had
all information on the fighting genre
within itself on a super decline it has
actually dropped 50% from previous years
so um that's the only reason why I was
bringing a topic up and being that it
was near and dear to us iron Lords our
heart because that was our crux of
Saturday's final yeah well I would like
other people to go first because I have
two examples of what a complete failure
absolutely Sam jumping room
all right so very quickly I think
personally that there's a few little
tweaks that can be made here there but
ultimately for fighting games it comes
down to the same three words content
content content accessibility is a
factor don't get me wrong a while the
people are sometimes put off by fighting
games because they're afraid to jump in
but really even more than that it comes
down to how much content is being added
that's why for honor is a very relevant
example because that game has stayed
strong it has over 1 million unique
players on all three platforms every
single month you can keep on adding more
content they keep on having more seasons
more characters more maps all this
different stuff that they add another
big success story is killer instinct
very big success started off a little
slow don't get me wrong it had some
quibbles and weebles and beginning but
they added content they add characters
they add the shadowlord's mode and the
story modes and all this other stuff
they believe it's had over nine million
ten billion players it's still going
strong so conversely look at the games
that aren't going strong they don't have
a clear roadmap of what content is going
to be added yeah you don't have a lot of
stuff good pardon me
for people to do laughs to cut you your
nail and it was sad because look at all
what's going on with injustice right
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles got people
going crazy right there at least what I
see yeah I don't know how to sales
numbers or but I see the level of
engagement I see the level of excitement
when they seem to drop these this this
continually great content content for
the game right right absolutely I
definitely saw way way more interest in
injustice to I mean after the initial
hype month obviously made sure but after
that the most I've seen anyone talking
about injustice to is when the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles were announced for
it we're just talking that gets people
interested again mm-hmm absolutely
Lord King like you wanted to attack this
thing all right because when I played
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite I thought it
was amazing but what I saw was a severe
lack of loved characters and that goes
into the owning of the IPS when you have
a mitad x-men which would have been a
staple of Marvel vs. Capcom before when
you remove Wolverine and Cyclops and
gambit and certain characters you take
away people that worked and cultivated
those characters and built off of those
characters and was looking forward to it
so those you took away sales when Disney
owns Marvel but don't own Fox this is
where licensees and problems and stuff
comes in that's where that game failed
so had that game had the original roster
of characters everyone that they were
able to use over 50 something characters
excellent involved in everything I think
the game would have been a lot more
successful because the storyline was
great um injustice this is a way of
seeing that they have no problem with
getting content and characters and
pulling from this place and Hellboy from
over here adding more DC characters like
the atom from all
here then teenage ninja ninja turtles
were a complete surprise so you was like
I definitely have to get this deal see
because I've never seen them in a
fighting game that was realistic to this
point fighting Superman into turtle did
you screenshot I retreated they did a
shell shock of the old for Turtles like
smashes I was tempted to get the gate
just ovale yeah that looks crazy I
played it this week and I did the move
and it was great it's like like like
Lord Sam says content and when you give
a clear roadmap to what's gonna come out
on and people can invest in DLC because
DLC is definitely the wave when it comes
to fighters and then when you building
off of the aspect of if your friends
have it or if you get online and you by
yourself is there other things for you
to do can you build your characters can
you put armor on your characters
I think injustice in this day and age
has nailed the fighting genre going
forward and I believe that should be the
format in the way fighting games are
used now he did say for honor and I use
I look at them in different aspects I
look at it as a confrontational game
because there's other things going
around in the world yeah you can fight
stuff over here and then make it over
here and control this part of the map
and you can fight this guy and take
control of this map so his other aspects
and more things going on than a
traditional fighter strike sure
I laughed that in the beginning because
remember it was on rubber legs and I was
calling it the Budokan in the beginning
before it flushed itself out and it
showed that it was able to stand the
test of time it was Budokan we loved we
loved Budokan Budokan but it evolved
into its own entity down that's what I'm
saying
so I completely agree with you guys on
the content for obviously adding more
content and having the roadmap to let
people know where you're going with the
game is important because
people invested my thing is that do you
think to continue to have the genre
expand and be in and opened up some more
people that normally wouldn't be in in
in interested in a genre and in turn
expanding the appeal of the genre in
general do you think that they have to
start doing something like in the vein
of a for honor where it's where they
create that sort of living environment
around the game rather than this
language it's interesting you said I'll
jump in because um I remember like some
of during Tekken's hey they would have
liked these modes like a Tekken force
right and you would do these kind of
quests like I even remember Soul Calibur
mm-hmm
it would have that weapons master mode
and you would it felt like a quest game
right and you would just go on and do
these quests and it just added all these
different depths and elements to the
game so I think you know that's why I
used to love Namco so much because when
I've ever that going to be still
probably still one of my top problems
you know that's it's just that like I
love the fact that when they put out a
fighting game it wasn't just the
fighting game and that was it you were
done had all these other modes and
things and going on and I know they
didn't subscribe DLC and stuff at the
time but um yeah it just always felt
like it added life to the game so I
think I think lore Sam's on it I think
it's it's one of those things that you
have to make it a beefier presentation
right also have to considerably like DLC
for fighting games specifically DLC is
very important it's very important you I
mean look at what the turtles are doing
and look at what you know for injustice
and you look at when they announce like
these really cool left-field characters
man it's it's really really something
that invigorates the franchise and um I
think that's the model you gotta go I
mean as far as now you are you going
like games as a service or like what are
you where you've also thinking about it
yeah something like that honestly just
like I said to expand the player base in
such a way that you would attract people
to this type of game that you'd normally
wouldn't because my thing is is every
single platform has its it's a plus and
minuses right when you look
Dragon Ball Z falling off 8% at PC my
immediate reaction to that well on the
PC
everything is so infinitely moddable
that the hardcore isn't gonna stay there
because it's very hard to play something
competitively on a platform where
there's just so many different changes
that can be made to the game at a
fundamental level right so to me that
that that makes sense right
on the console side I think that's where
the competitive core sort of stay right
constant you don't really have our kids
anymore so the competitive courts gonna
stay with the consoles and just to me it
just feels like okay those are the guys
that are sticking around with the game
those are the ones that even regardless
of how much you do see you're getting
they're gonna continue to play the game
because they enjoy the systems of the
game right but the systems of it as such
with fighting games like the onboarding
process to any fighting game is it's
really uphill it's very difficult to get
somebody not interested in that already
to be willing to put the time in mmm to
master something like I think Dragon
Ball Z did a very good job of creating a
game that has depth but on its surface
can be enjoyed and played by just
mashing buttons and you see a bunch of
cool stuff I was looking at a game that
was released um on ps4 the game is
called under night in berth exe lady you
know it's one of the longer Japanese
anime inspired game right here but the
onboarding it does is kind of cool
because it's a tutorial that takes you
through something close to like 180
lessons about the fighting systems
within that game and just generally
things that you wouldn't need to do to
be on board onto any game in the
fighting genre and what it does is
interesting and it'll tell you like okay
you did that you did this move it was
cool you didn't do it perfectly you're
not quite ready to take on somebody
one-on-one it tells you like you suck
you need to give but at the same time is
holding your hand in the process so
again it's things that these games need
to do to sort of bring people in and
keep them from being afraid of the
mechanics of a fighting game right
now I'm way back when I talked about
that game rising Thunder the Seth
Killian was developing that kind of got
nixed when they got bought out but it
was a game that required very little
input but again had depth in terms of
you knowing these characters what
canceled what out so there was still
depth there but the onboarding process
in terms of in terms of systems and
learning you know quarter-circle forward
half circle forward you know stuff like
that wasn't there if it was there if you
wanted it but usually it very simply and
again to me
i think the fighting genre it wants to
expand and not continue to kind of be on
this you know the slow downward trend i
think it needs to start thinking about
how they do that I think it's gonna be
interesting to see what Soul Calibur
does it's here cuz so so we're on
caliber right area my man killings back
I am I need the I'm kill what happened
for anybody else I'm selfish killings
back looking like so callable one kill
yeah
fur on the neck staff like what because
people forget that's all as always put
respectful connect named Lord King know
when we first saw Soul Calibur for
Dreamcast or whatever and you saw that
cata of him all staff that's what me
shout out the maxi to do do you remember
we had to use the PC in your Mazal shout
out to your mom she's the greatest woman
he is the greatest woman who ever walked
this earth her level of patience huh Zen
isn't second to none you had a sweaty
boyes inside her womb downloading this
kata in the kata take like five hours
watch this was on that PC and Lord
Cognito was the most intrusive child
ever
there's no glow kid you just took me
back first of all break it down why did
we have to be your PC to do this I don't
even remember sources that I had to get
low so we can watch a preview of again
it's like before right now Emma and
GamePro GamePro said that if the if you
follow the link the link sent you to
where Namco was putting up the live like
cuz they will show you wireframes of
games and stuff like that but they had
the textures in and it was showing the
movements and how fluid the characters
was one of the first characters that was
shown was Killick because he was though
you went to the fighting genre using a
poll staff and he's such a degree that
it was realistic factually one good
question cuz I'm my timeline I'm old
Lord now you know yeah what's the
timeline was so callable one before
Tekken 3 who did Cottagers
I'm trying to think who did cards
because I remember her Ankara but I
remember the soul Kyle of Mikayla kata
the first cottage that was ever done was
virtual fighters yeah through digital
children I mean like the ones with good
motion technique great motion capture
remember doses polygons moving in a
realistic manner no we can't take away
from the fly his ninja kata it wasn't I
mean technically we still playstation
one right so all right shut out to sting
in the khakis correctness we got some og
lords in here he said he was just about
to say he's correcting me
he said Virtua Fighter is too and I
forgot for two three go yeah he's
correct because they had they kind of
had those intro sequences in the car
you're right you have not at oh yeah
because the remember that
the drunken munkey mask yeah you are
correct
get you on the show 1999 he has to
remember was a launch title for the
Dreamcast I'm just trying to get the
time line between Tekken because it
farzat my opinion the best Coty's was
killing so caliber and max Oh max it was
lit because that was the first nunchucks
and everything and then detecting three
counters with the drunken but the most
realistic drunken mess that you have
ever seen yes yes so we have we have
some real stuff we had some rust them so
yeah shout out shout out to you know
lady Lady Gaga between my dad 14-4 modem
or maybe 30 360 AOL dial-up
I won't I will never forget it because
it felt so intrusive and she was just
like hey guys I didn't do it you know
and I'm like wow man that's great mom's
watching
yes absolutely
back to the vector vein flakes that we
could figure yeah I mean honestly from
my point of view it's like I want to
continue to see the fighting game genre
thrive I want to see them do some things
I would just shout out to Tom and end
the chat we're talking about like an egg
a true MK RPG or an RP any RPG with
these fighting game characters because I
mean again when it comes to story
stories kind of nonsensical a lot of
these fighting games would like it to be
better I would like to see you know
genres expanded a little bit with these
characters and not necessarily only be
fighting games but at the same time
within the fighting games I think it
would it would do great to just expand
you know things like you know the way
you get do the way you get different
color shades of costumes in the game
where you get move that's efficient Lou
understand the evolution of share
Oh G has paved the way for everything
I'm saying it's because I was completely
biased when my game got overrun he was
like you don't open well if I gave him
very Shen was that yes that was the
first you know absolutely
absolutely it be it just to see
hopefully it comes out this year you
know we see but I heard um did they get
a new publisher some very heartening
here I didn't believe it at first I was
browsing recent era and someone brought
up and I was like no surely not then I
was up so we gotta back things up here
we gotta wind the clocks back though
here's the Shenmue 3 announcement III
year of dreams you know it came out on
stage
Kickstarter all that it was incredible
my - edit here I'm not no man I'm a
grown man what happens that's very
interesting is Sony merely helped with
the funding to an undisclosed amount
they aren't publishing the game that's
something a lot of people don't know
Deep Silver acquired somehow I don't
understand how but Deep Silver actually
have the publishing rights for Shenmue 3
walked in and in paper it's in the
contract
but Deep Silver as we all know just got
picked up by a certain THQ Nordic Nord
is basically put THQ back together again
as close as it ever will be which is
fantastic THQ was one of the last real
double-a publishers in the industry it's
great to see THQ Nordic becoming a
powerhouse so it raises the very
interesting question where does that
leave Shenmue 3 coming to multiply
believe that was the whole thing about
it I
I'm going to agree at this point I do
not think it launched I don't I don't
think there's any way it happens but I
think six months 12 months 18 months
after it comes out you'll see it making
its way to other platforms and that
would be huge this is a huge nugget that
you drop in Los now I would tend to
[Music]
money and it seems like this of aspect
or agreements that was going that the
people wasn't privy to just get started
thing has to Scott the Deaf singing it
to ankle ankle men mentioned the game
that I champions earlier on this last
year talking up solver solver when
you're talking about a fighting
open-world RPG absorbers a game where as
you move through the game the more
opponents you fight you learn their
moves and then you have a skill tree
that you can set moves up as you see fit
your favorite moves you can you can
prioritize certain things like it's very
customizable and it's like and it's one
of those things like the game itself
like aesthetically is kind of very
simple but at its core that's what I
mean by that that replayability that
sort of grinding nature that yeah coming
back to the game yeah great exact great
example shot they're gonna check also
last one I want to make too is that um I
don't know if you guys got a chance to
see the fix to the north star new trail
that got me excited it looked like it
had some long-term elements and it had a
little shed new element Olivia like a
sega system where genesis are Saturn or
something that you can play in the game
with something like I'm like yo shadow
shout out the Lord Jacobus came on the
show you know was a fighting game he
actually stood he was very very hype
about as well he actually meets with the
Lords back on it but yeah that's
definitely one I got my eye on I've
always been a fan of North Star series
and actually I'd educate myself because
as a sacred kid I didn't know about it
and I thought last battle was the
really it was the knockoff Americanized
mr. the dogs dog so it was just funny to
learn like another thing we haven't
talked about in that vein yeah yeah yeah
6 is this year and it's the same type of
thing where it's like you you gain means
you games that you go open world again
it goes back to all the way with the box
you gotta check it out check it out
because this is probably the funniest
story it is the funniest story there
look I need oh and I have right money
and at this point Strider was 16 it was
16 Meg's right
$80 at crazy sounds he got his money
together
$80 back then there's a lot of money so
he got he got his money he went down the
crazy sounds and he purchased the game
not know I'm annoying this to kognito I
played this game an arcade all the time
arcade all the time every day every day
right he got the cartridge in his house
the second he put his cartridge in I was
like can i play he's like yeah I ended
his game I didn't die I ended his game
or the first character first it was
payback because he got me back good
let's give the contest he'll fury and
that game and his time was extremely
hard right so I used to pick Andy Bogart
and cheese one move it was all him our
judge and he came over to my house and I
told him these power is probably the
hardest character ever I can't beat him
he stated it now he proceeded to cheese
him with this stupid-ass elbow and made
my 250 dollar cartridge irrelevant I buy
the games I play them first
hi Basu new you do not touch that game
not remove not remove the shrink-wrap
from that game because I know if he gets
his hands on
it's a wrap save like it was like a rite
of passage back to me zero you bought
these games you know sixteen or whatever
the rule was you invited your friends
over to see the game but there was
unwritten rule that as a friend that is
being allowed to see that game you are
not allowed to finish money we went to
the mom-and-pop sure we bought the
cartridge we came home it was more you
know over despair especially the rule
was up the debut of a brand new system a
brand new system inviting you over there
hey check out my Atari Japanese I'm
gonna save the destiny bereted stuff we
gotta do he had to get out of his PC
unfortunately definitely crapped out up
so we gotta give our condolences to a
lot annex PC hopefully get his stuff
together but with the successful release
of remakes and remastered like a Shadow
of the Colossus and last of us - should
these types of titles warrant re review
the answer choices are a yes they should
be reviewed again on its own merit
B no only review the tech advancements
and improvements or C I don't care I
hate all these cash-grab
remasters that is the question those are
the choices we will put this up so
please Rock the Vote at the ILP for the
polls tomorrow when it goes up Lord Sam
Roth of Rivia at the round table back
again where can I find people find you
and what else do you have going on well
first off thank you for having me on
here again my official debut as part of
the inner circle games it was fantastic
we will absolutely have to do it again
sometime we're gonna have to hit up some
pub G and other games together all over
and we can all agree so if you're
interested in finding me and following
me on Twitter don't say I didn't warn
you but you can do so at Samuel Tolbert
it's very simple very easy to find me
and if you're interested in what I write
or you just want to talk and in the
comment sections of the forums you can
find me on T icgn dot-com where I'm
either writing something reviewing
something or playing it so I can then
write about it and review it Lord Sam
always editing correcting my foolish
writing you gotta get you back gonna
read much appreciate it that is my guy
right there absolutely love Sam and love
what you're doing out here you know I'm
saying the UM the article was just
really really good high-quality man very
very high quality and always always on
the scoops one of the best young writers
and please check him out he's now family
with the inner circle so we can
officially call him bread drink love it
Lord software can define people find you
coming through is great to be on a
podcast with him finally yeah and then
they can find me on
[Applause]
I really been online being sovereign on
PSN and Xbox Live and Mosab I'll be on
Twitter
absolutely Lord gig raha Lord Sam it's
been a pleasure sir and I'm pretty sure
that you're going to jump on some pub
Jean Oh like some pub ji poaching that's
not even listen that's not even a thing
I already know what your hangs out with
means now I'll go back this doesn't
matter
oh I'm about to throw on the slippers
I'm about to get some cognac or put on
the rope and I'm going to put on the
headset I'm gonna get into some murk and
murder yes I will be on some pub G right
now sir
this is about to happen so you can catch
me on an Instagram Facebook Twitter
King David OTW hit me up and I'm
definitely hitting me up on xbox if you
haven't added me Agni trust me this is
the PG version Lords after dark and if
you easily offended don't add me love
what you do it out here Lord kid you got
everyone shot the monkey punch you know
shoutout to what was it dance singer you
you got a relevant you got like a whole
sub G squadron man shout out the rant if
you still here like we were talking
about we would love to have like you
know cloud server as your you know 100
man everybody we're doing rotations that
we have people waiting is the match over
socket jumping yeah so I really want to
get to the point where either the squads
get expanded something happens to the
point where I can have all I want to run
a 16-man team cuz I really believe I can
pack it with 16 dupes facts man absolute
ol or si he here chillin he said what's
up heal or overhead just said it right
his timeline is real y'all heat up
chicken dinners he gets it in so yes we
got a link up with Lauren definitely get
this pub G going but yeah buddy's law
kognito hear the gaming realness was
spread thanks for every old chat was
absolutely lick today thank you so much
for coming
and a shout out to the Lord I really
miss you I was in the UK I've like
chomping at the bit Eggar bear healthy
back everyone well you know say so I
also support the multiverse tomorrow
though anchorman will be going live we
will correct his top 5 I'm gonna have to
play the peacemaker here otherwise we're
gonna have your circle Civil War it's
gonna be the Civil War
you know we gonna have to come you're
gonna mean undead of course might be the
truth you know saying in a premium Brit
I think he's been going away acne are
tomorrow at 8 p.m. also subscribe to the
inner circle Network and of course the
iron law podcast you know YouTube
channel I also been doing flashpoints
with Lori bonds has a shout out to doc
amnesia man the guy broke the internet
with the us gamer article please check
that out it's on the island podcast
YouTube we know I got a lot of support
from the Destiny community and just a
heartfelt love letter to the people who
love destiny one and what we loved about
it my destiny - wasn't that and again no
bashing just from a heartfelt positive
perspective so please catch that if you
can and like I said we're gonna get the
audio and all that stuff up as soon as
possible thanks again everyone for
coming through enjoy your Sunday and
we're about to be out of here please